the Joe Rogan experience the question
you're getting at is how did Comanches
in particular because when when these
dodge and Catelyn and these various
people saw Comanches in Texas in
eighteen thirties they just flat
couldn't believe what they were looking
at they they couldn't believe their
abilities with horses breaking them yeah
I've never seen anything like it before
I'd never seen anything like it no
saddle eater right now the ad the other
did have a cell yeah I think that was
part of the Spanish technology very very
very minimal you'll see it museums but
do you say you can find one of those see
I'm a Spanish saddle or anyway but yeah
they they had and and but particularly
the the shooting there it is right there
very minimal minimal yes and one of the
ways they could shoot underneath the the
the neck of the horse was to hang a
thong off side of one of the saddles but
a thong well loop a leather loop a
leather loop that would allow them
because otherwise they they would need
to be supported as long as they came
down underneath them there were fairly
small people they were they were fairly
small people so they're like they would
kind of climb off the saddle and hang on
the side on this side full gallop full
gallop shooting under the neck
accurately arrows that would kill a man
at 30 yards underneath in there but
people so the question there I don't
know the answer to that and I don't know
that anyone does what the white men saw
just absolutely floored them with
abilities with arrows and among other
things they would you know they would
make the Indian would ask the Indian
voice they set up a dime in a tree or a
coin and they go cane out here
you stand here and like close your eyes
and aim and hit that the Comanche boy
would miss it by the foot look at that
picture right there of them do that's
Aristotle underneath the so the
basically using the horse as a shield
yeah yeah that's the whole idea
Wow and there and and if you see them
from the other side I've seen trick
riders do this you can't even see them
mmm from the other side of the horse and
again this was something that you know
trick riders after you know in the Wild
West shows and Beyond would
do these sorts of things but I'm sorry
so I'll go back to what you're saying so
when they were standing still
well oh so with the Comanche boy there
asked him to like shoot that diamond
kenchi boy wouldn't hit I mean he was he
was - he was playing by their rules they
wanted him to stand and aim and whatever
and again if you see the Lars Andersson
videos there was no such thing as
closing one eye there was no such thing
almost as standing still and shooting it
was constant movement it was you know
shooting from movement wherever they
were going so and so so we can hear it
that way so it was sort of like the
member in Butch Cassidy and the Sundance
Kid where they say here Sundance try to
hit that and and you know Sundance Kid
shoots at it and misses it and then on
his way out he moves he says you mind if
I move or something or I'm better if I
move it's the same deal yeah it was all
about movement and it was never about
anything stationary mm-hmm anyway so you
know that that dancer I have no idea how
they got good at that right that's why
it's a real shame that they don't have a
written history yeah I mean that's one
of many many things that's a real shame
that they don't have a written history
because it's a and I would have loved to
have seen someone be able to do that I
mean God what how incredible would it be
to see what what it looked like to see
them I mean we're just we just missed
the motion picture by 60 70 years gotta
think they were doing it for hundreds
hundreds and hundreds use it's almost
like just too magical to capture sorry
it's gone you have gone right before
you'd invent a camera no at least we
have some photos some still photos we do
and we have and I put in pretty big
chunks of text into my book of people of
the time who saw them and who described
it yeah that's all you can do is yeah
this just what they saw and how
astounded they were we must have been
pretty excited when you saw that Lars
Anderson guy oh yeah because you know I
pull that guy up show up pull up a video
that guy so we could watch it because it
is pretty amazing and because I mean I
it's not that I didn't believe what I
was reading but on some level it's hard
to believe that they can do what the
people said they could do it's
interesting because this guy gets hated
on a lot in the archery community it's
very funny because
you know they say that a lot of what
he's doing is tricks and a lot always
doing his nonsense and you know it's not
really true that people actually did
that but watch him do it yes I said okay
man I'm the big meanie unless that's a
trick I mean he's clearly doing what
he's saying he's doing there's no if
ands or buts about it yeah are they
tricks in terms of like is it something
that like maybe wouldn't be as effective
but it's really cool to see yeah for
sure but so what so what he's still
showing you yeah he's showing you that
you can do things I mean but is he
throws a ball and then shoots look at
you shoot it was look at that he shoot
it in in the head with his also the rate
of discharge which is one of the things
I had trouble believing he when you see
him shoot he's just yeah one every
second
throws it catches it and he can shoot an
arrow like after right after he catches
it look at that how you throw something
in the air and then shoots two shots two
he throws it in the air and then by the
time it hits the ground he hits it twice
means incredible and he's really
accurate with this thing
he also one of his cases is that you
know that he is always moving it's
continuous movement he never he doesn't
close one eye he doesn't stand still he
is moving all the time yeah where he
goes which is what he said was a
trademark of the great the Magyars and
the great you know Archer cultures look
at this jumps in the air gets off an
arrow before he hits the ground I mean
amazing and he's even catching arrows
and then shooting him back like anybody
that says that what he's doing is the
nonsense is a fool
like look I'm only doing it he said
you're an you are an archer yeah archery
range back then okay so you got it I'm a
bow under yeah well okay that's how this
is really impressive stop for me I don't
shoot traditional archery I shoot a
compound bow with a sight and I can line
it up to the exact yardage and all that
stuff but but I know enough to know that
what this guys doing it's pretty special
so he's showing arrows in the quiver
versus arrows in his hand how he can
just grab them and pull them right so
his his case is that we all think that
it's a quiver right he says nobody
nobody who was any good ever used a
quiver
you can transport them in a quiver but
in battle you're holding them in a bunch
a clustered bunch and you
and I'm saying these people here in
these ancient depictions the actual
drawings from you know hundreds of years
ago of the way he did it holding the
arrows in his draw hand and so he can do
it very quickly really interesting it is
really and this is probably I mean
because of this one gentleman it's
probably the only way we're really gonna
know that this was possible cuz no one
else is doing anything like this guy
look at this guy he's doing drive-bys on
a back of a bike and he hits I mean back
that up again so you could see that
because that is insane
watch how he's doing this right there I
mean three times he hits in in a second
he hits three targets on a bike as he's
riding by which would emulate a horse
other than the difference between the
elevation change you know that you go up
and down on a horse but that was the
other thing about like the stories of
the Mongols that they had developed an
ability to shoot as the horses in the
air because they wouldn't like the the
stomping oh I say hubs would during that
part so as the horse was up that's when
they would release so it would have the
least amount of impact on their their
accuracy pretty incredible stuff but
it's one of the things that made
Comanches Comanches the mastery of the
horse Plus that would now combine with
this ability to shoot from from a moving
horse now did they have a particular
prowess with archery that was was known
amongst Native Americans what was
extraordinary
amongst other tribes I don't know that
for a fact but I do know the reaction of
people who saw them who had seen plenty
of other Indians nobody had ever seen
anything like it at the time now was
there a group in of Northern Plains
Indians that could do I don't know but
but the reaction was almost universal by
people who had seen a lot of Indian
tribes and you know they'd never seen
that before
[Applause]